ah
a
okay I am a tick talker I knew it I knew
I could tell I do like mostly fashion
stuff like secondhand fashion vintage
stuff and lifestyle what do you sell I
don't really anymore I started like my
Tick Tock promoting my online vintage
shop and that's how I became a tick
tocker and now I just like do fashion
stuff do you do it full time yeah sure
so your Revenue comes from sponsored
yeah it's like all social media now I
don't know fashion makes like no money
unless you're a thin white woman
so
so she's a thin white woman so why did
he do it like that with the Crickets
[__]
[Music]
I don't know why she was like well this
is kind of boring [__]
and so many skinny women so if you can
if you can if you can fashion makes like
no money unless you're a thin white
woman
being plus size in the social media
industry is definitely been hard there's
visibly fat plus size people and then
there's people with the quintessential
perfect curves like almost unfortunately
how plus size are you how plus size are
you just sounds like a funny thing
forget plus size you literally just take
the plus simple and just turn on a sign
just X you multiply
if you do a lifestyle but you're a small
Creator you get nothing like they
literally only gifting campaigns and
then like even then they Gaslight you
into feeling like you should be grateful
for it yeah absolutely given I'm
guessing you sound like you're a very
large Creator and then like I feel like
I've seen your videos on my free page I
would maybe put you first oh don't do
that yeah I'm also this is like my first
year doing this yeah right here I don't
think I make more than you we still have
time to switch let's try okay so I am a
plus size supermodel so everything I do
is pretty much lifestyle around that
so
what does it mean to be a supermodel
give me two seconds
there's a difference between
modeling
model
and supermodel
um
when you're modeling you're modeling
once in a while and you do your thing or
that's like that's your
once in a while thing okay you practice
that
okay
when you're a model that's your main
income
when you're a supermodel
the way you depicted the fact that it
was hard
that's not a supermodel supermodel work
work
so
I would
supermodel are no known it's like a
superstar
of the model industry you understand
what I'm saying what's her name Ashley
Grahams
whatever her name is that's a supermodel
I could consider that I don't know who
you are girl that's not super I feel
like every year the um
the definitions for some of these words
just change my understanding every six
months yeah and I'm just like
am I behind the times where do you rank
like what's your percentage on only fans
I'm 0.01
okay
yeah yeah I mean well she said she did
only veins I was looking at him like she
looks like she takes all the dicks
how many guys you've been with um I used
to do
Adam 22. yeah listen I don't even want
to hear what she said I see Adam 22 and
I'm like she definitely makes money she
definitely does some foul [__] too
um I used to do parties and I would get
like 50 dudes a night okay so you're on
no jump she got ran through by 50 dude
she's 15. 15 is less 50 dudes at night
15 years at night she said 50 50. she
said
G Unit that's two whole football teams
am I sure no but it sounds good it's two
football teams that's an NFL game just
running through her all them collisions
down the boom boom
Hey listen there were a lot of
touchdowns scored that day if it's not
too field goals too if it's not some of
that [__] ended up in the stance let me
just say they even had a marching band
run through I'm telling you that feel
was muddy by the end of the [__] oh my
God and it didn't rain not water you get
what I'm trying to say 50 news in one
night but she makes money yeah she gonna
sell her soul that hard soon I bet she
does so my photo is a photo of me in
Vogue
um so it's a beautiful photo my butt's
in Vogue
my days
okay congrats on your new baby insert
cash or select payment type money to
complete transaction I'm sorry what I
don't care well no buses like a lot of
popular Tick Tock content is cringe this
is my dad and this is his at home work
setup he hates it so today I'm gonna try
to fix it I'm gonna first add a custom
keyboard I built for him and a mouse and
then we're gonna go ahead and give him
the fopo triple monitor laptop adapter
this is going to turn his single laptop
screen into a triple Monitor and our
nose is smooshed up against our kissing
partner's face is actually opening up
our nostrils and making their pheromones
more obvious to us that just coming from
a girl with a big nose it's just funny
it sounds like it sounds like I got to
deal with this big nose and I'm gonna
let you know it's good for you that's
what it sounds like Hey listen I've I've
been with some beacons you understand
what beacons
you can see them from the sky okay God
bless them I don't care toucan can get
it too Froot Loops and
and I'm not gonna lie to you it just
need a bit of a health tip that's it you
still kissing I got a bit of allergies I
bet you do you understand there's gonna
be some transitions from when you go
here you're gonna have to go okay you're
gonna have to go some back and forth to
get to the other side yeah let's say I
say you might have to do something
another nose but it's just a thing ain't
no time I'm ready with a girl's nose and
be like yo hey why can't I breathe
better that don't happen okay just want
to say that
but
let me some big noses shout outs to you
your body will actually react to that
person's pheromones and can make you
more attracted to them if your body
thinks they're a good biological match
how many hours do you guys work I work
every day a lot like this week I worked
like four 18-hour days at minimum
there's no day where I'm working like
almost every single day where I'm
working less than five hours
at least I'm not trying to diminish what
they were saying like it is hard work
and like when she was talking about like
oh like work doesn't end but like it's
like it does you can go get a smoothie
and like sit in your bed and scroll
emails it's not the same as like being
expected to be somewhere and like be a
slave all day and be off your phone like
you're not a person when you're at work
but like you're a person when you're
doing this
skinny white [__] preaching
now shout outs to her she doing her
thing she right okay this work I do it
is hard work is it harder than some of
the other jobs I had hell [__] no
do I have more flexibility hell [__]
yes does it demand weird hours sometimes
absolutely but I would not sit here and
just oh my God I work like you could you
still choose your hours you know what I
mean exactly those hours don't have to
be that weird and you can scale back
production and and still make so much
money you ever would have made anyways I
could work three hours a week and still
make two three times okay what I made on
my previous job so at the end of the day
I'm not gonna sit here and be with that
[__] like oh my God influencer like
you know that's cringe that's crazy it
is a lot of work and there's a lot of
there's a lot to
there's a lot to take care of and
there's a lot but it's it's not
you think I want to go back I don't want
to go back look I don't wanna I don't
want to go back any of these I don't
want to go back any of these people try
to sell you on like there's downsides
okay cool we can be honest about that
but it's hard to when you do a job like
this because at first I was like oh I
don't actually you know work that many
hours but then it's like the second I
wake up I'm checking and I'm deciding
what I'm gonna do today
yeah yeah so it's hard when you're not
doing it like you know what I got a hard
time man 18 hours a day
that's what she claimed
so that's what she said
oh yeah that's why I got I did I did
four days of 18 hours and I'm like
liar liar pants on super fire
nah the they capping so hard four hours
their idea of 14 hours this is their
idea of work they scroll some emails
reply to the stuff browse YouTube grab
some food or go back to work talk to
some friends go back to work travel
somewhere all this to them is all hard
it's not the same thing it's not I've
seen a lot of YouTubers who claim they
work hard and I watch them they not
working hard I got a lot of things going
on and sometimes I can't chill or
sometimes I'm not in the mindset to
respond to emails because I'm doing a
lot of [__]
but
yeah nah it's not it's you know nope
what what that was a shocker no way six
spot Haley
[Music]
there you go you doing four days 18 my
girl you need to work smarter
no way 120 and here's the thing these
are great incomes for the [__] that
they have to do these are amazing
incomes but the way she was talking down
amazing
six figure Club
fourth spot Grace 180k
and the third spot Josh
275. I love like those guys who got
businesses like running Tech creating
computers laptop screens we got girls
running clothes fashion clothes doing
brand deals and then the others just
selling their [__] and they making more
than everybody
of course Hey listen the oldest
profession still sometimes be looking
like the most profitable and she didn't
disclose how many of she had nope right
and think about this too some of y'all
came in about that never forget it's
dudes paying
000 men every month have to give 20
bucks for her to get that chance oh man
you know these yo these girls are going
to Dubai is up
your opinion Dubai while she's the Dubai
is home kasumi's probably seven figures
yeah easy we're up here and in the
second spot Raya 300K and the first spot
Kazumi
told you okay it wasn't even close once
I see 21 000 Pages Landslide yeah it
wasn't even close I have an anomaly and
I don't represent what all sex workers
make I make a lot of money but it is
still something that you should deeply
consider before getting into because it
is something that has holds a lot of
social stigma and does make life hard if
you don't like doing it yeah I just want
50 black dudes to just walk in right
behind her and stand there she gives
that answer and just pause
are you ready for this 3 million because
you're gonna have to pay and uh I just
want to say that y'all have motivated me
because I feel like I became like
comfortable with what I was doing and
like I haven't been pushing myself
recently but now I'm like y'all are
doing so well I'm like now
I'm just so inspired by how many people
have seen your butthole I think there's
an idea of what an influencer is in
people's heads and I think it's usually
like a air-headed person who just takes
selfies or uses a selfie stick they
don't understand I think maybe the
Nuance like I was kind of weird coming
into it because I grew up really poor
and like 180 000 is like so much money
to me I like I would be happy making the
amount of money I make right now for the
rest of my life and I feel like everyone
gets into it and they're like I have to
be a millionaire and I have to like
monetize every category of my life and
that's probably where it becomes like an
insane job
facts Grace is speaking facts facts
um Hey listen guys
them numbers
but there you guys have it if we were
chicks and we had some titties
and we open only veins probably making
10 times what I make right now
easy easy peasy easy easy if I didn't
have these videos just naked on only
fans only how many people pay for them I
mean there's women who ask right now and
I'm like that's weird I ain't doing that
but if I was a woman to do it hey you
know but you just you got to sell your
soul a little bit
you willing to do that preach no I'm
good
well let us know what you guys think in
the comments below how do you guys feel
about skinny white wages
yeah
yeah it was kind of
really okay calm down girl cheers